be sure to check out my second channel
called Rob explains there you can check
out videos where I explain things
outside of comic books so while I was
planning to do another omega-level
mutant video today I was going through
my list and realize I had forgotten one
of the mutants of Marvel Comics who is
considered to be beyond omega-level and
so what I want to do here is have a
discussion about mr. M which will
actually wrap up our explanation on
characters who are beyond omega-level
mutant so for those of you who were new
to my youtube channel the concept of a
mutant being omega-level was introduced
as part of Grant Morrison's run on new
x-men in the early 2000s up to this
point mutants were simply considered to
be powerful
with the stories themselves providing us
with an explanation of who is considered
to be the most powerful however because
different characters were written
differently by various writers the
powers they possessed changed based on
the circumstances meaning that there was
no universal standard and so the
introduction of omega-level
classifications in Marvel allowed us as
the reader to gain a better
understanding of who the most powerful
mutants were as well as how they were
viewed by other heroes and organizations
within the realm of Marvel Comics that
said the character of mr. M or Absalom
Mercator first appeared in the
short-lived series district X written by
David hind district X was both the name
of a location within the Marvel Universe
as well as a series spearheaded by
editor-in-chief Joe Quesada as serving
as part of Posadas revolution line of
comics which functioned to reboot the
x-men series for the modern reader
district X existed as one half of the
equation with the other half being NYX
which will be covered in my explanation
video on X 23 as part of Graham
Morrison's overall reworking of the
x-men series fighter David Heine
stablished that because of the various
issues involving racism and bigotry
towards mutants on behalf of humans a
handful of mutants came together to form
their own community within New York's
alphabet city so named due to the fact
that each Street is named after a single
letter of the alphabet covered within
the entirety of the series first six
issues what we're told is that because
New York itself falls under the
jurisdiction of the NYPD district X is
no exception
however because of the community's wide
array of powers owing to its
overpopulation of mutants as well as
prostitution violence in poverty
the police were effectively outmatched
in their entirety being completely
unable to apprehend mutant criminals by
conventional means while this would spin
out into the
production of the futuristic mutant
Bishop as a member of the community self
policing tactics in order to both ensure
safety and assuage the community's
distrust of humans regarding Absalon
Mercator he was referred to as mr. M by
both the children and the communities
inhabitants out of both respect and fear
despite largely keeping to himself
covered in entry number four which
focused on mr. Aames backstory what
we're told is that as a child he had
come upon his cousin being bullied
attempting to get the bully to stop
Epsilon reached out and touched him
resulting in the bully being turned
inside out
now we're Absalon tells us that the
bully lived like this for three days the
implication here is that someone or
something reversed the process or else
the bully died but regardless Absalon
was hidden by his parents and smuggled
into the United States where he had
lived with relatives for a majority of
his life now starting to point out here
is that by his own admission epsilon had
watched from the shadows as the various
superheroes of the world formed into
teams or operated solo carrying out
their various roles within the Marvel
Universe what this meant was that during
the events of the onslaught saga
operation zero-tolerance House of M
civil war and the death of Captain
America Epsilon had been in existence
but chose not to act due to his
experiences as a child to this end
epsilon simply took to making his way in
the world taking odd jobs here and there
eventually settling a mutant town after
its formation now with regards to his
powers epsilon Mercator is capable of
altering the molecular structure of
anything he touches granting him the
power to warp reality now something I
want to point out here is that Absalon
is not on the same level as Franklin
Richards or Matthew Malloy and while
there is no hierarchy of power once you
get above Omega level if there were
different stages Absalon would be well
below Franklin and Matthew the reason
for this is that unlike both Franklin
and Matthew Absalon has to physically
touch something in order to manipulate
its molecules at the same time David
Hein dowels into a bit of contradiction
here what I mean is that while
explaining his powers Absalon states
that he could initiate a nuclear
explosion using his powers wiping out
the entirety of New York and the
surrounding area where this requires us
to be a little speculative with atomic
explosions occurring by splitting the
atom because the oxygen that epsilon
breeze contains atoms it would seem that
Absalon is capable of detonating those
atoms but again this is a stretch at
best and at worst it's absolute nonsense
but regardless of how that would work
the fact remains that because of his
ability to manipulate matter through
contact
Absalon can instantly heal from any
injury so long as brain function remains
control the function and workings of all
machines activate or negate the Newton
powers of others manipulate and control
energy on a subatomic level
transform anything into anything else by
altering its molecular structure as well
as grant himself telepathy telekinesis
and increases on durability -
indestructible levels however because
the district X line of stories which
short lived in the face of Marvel's
House of M which reduced the overall
population of mutants much like Franklin
Richards and most likely due to his
ability to manipulate matter mr. M
retained his powers despite the squat at
which his actions now again because
there were a handful of mutants who
retained their powers some of whom were
as powerful as Scarlet Witch while
others were weaker there's no method for
us to measure the powers of mr. M and
relation this phone at which however
with the fallout of House of M launching
decimation which focused on the
aftermath of the mutant populations
reduction and an effort to ensure the
remainder of the population went forward
without fear of elimination the
president activated the office of
national emergency which in turn
deployed sentinel squad 1 which
contained the now-famous machines albion
operating by pilots stationing
themselves at the Xavier Institute under
the continued writing of David Hein
Marvel launched the 5 issue limited
series titled 198 which dealt with the
remaining mutants who were not featured
in the larger x-men title and how they
handled the signal occupation that said
whether through convenience or editorial
direction the powers of mr. M were
modified and that rather than having to
make physical contact in order to modify
matter mr. M simply had to be in the
general vicinity of an object or person
as a result Epsilon began traveling
around the Xavier Institute offering his
powers as a means to cure ailments
suffered by mutants who wish to
physically appear normal in addition to
this because Charles Xavier had remained
missing following the house of M with
Emma Frost and Cyclops taking over as
heads of the school during a meeting on
the status of the Institute's occupants
Epsilon is officially declared an
omega-level mutant in Marvel Comics now
for those of you who are new to the
Marvel landscape within marvel comics
there are those who are considered to be
possibly Omega level verified Omega
level and beyond Omega level for mutants
like storm who can control the elements
or magneto who can manipulate the
electromagnetic spectrum
fans largely considered them to be
potentially or unverified Omega
mutants what this means is that in
essence they have all the qualifications
for being an omega-level mutant
regarding their power being strong
enough to lay waste to the planet or
else having no upper limit to their
capabilities but they have never been
verified as an omega-level mutant per se
now transitioning to his powers again
because mister am presented an anomaly
and that his abilities were well beyond
the scope of either the x-men or
humanity fighter david Hein revealed
that despite all his abilities mr. M
like all mutants of Marvel Comics fell
victim to the powers of leech beside
track for a second during his run on the
x-men title and in an effort to beef up
the total number of mutants fighter
Chris Claremont created leech as a
mutant with the power to shut down the
powers of other mutants serving as
somewhat of a trump card with Absalom
Mercator intending to move the remaining
mutants away from the Xavier Institute
while a handful followed the desire
Cyclops was to ensure the survival of
all remaining mutants by keeping the
confined in one location and tending to
retrieve those who followed mr. M
Cyclops initiated a battle between the
two groups with leech depowering mr. M
after which magma used her powers to
control molten rock to destroy Absalom
Mercator entirely well that being said
we're going to bring this video to an
end it's relatively short but that's
really just because mr. M only appeared
in about 16 issues and Marvel Comics and
so if you guys enjoyed this video make
sure you guys drop a like make sure you
leave a comment and make sure you guys
hit the subscribe button to become part
of the Rob core and I will catch you
guys later peace